j'ai le Corto commissaire la Ligue de
hockey junior majeur du Québec et
finalement avec nous ce cours tout
bonsoir
bonsoir vous avez entendu le Premier
ministre qui était furieux
le commissaire de la Ligue il réagit pas
vous étiez où hier monsieur Courtot
canadienne de hockey était pour sortir
au niveau de
l'explication suite à l'article de
Martin Leclerc il y a rien eu qui était
fait de ce côté-là qui aujourd'hui on a
décidé de se rendre disponible bon ok
hier on vous avait demandé hier mais
c'est cela dit vous étiez en poste
toutes ces années-là qu'on décrit dans
les dans les scènes d'horreur que décrit
Martin Leclerc dans quelle mesure vous
étiez au courant dans quelle mesure il y
avait des coachs des entraîneurs qui
étaient au courant de ce qui se passait
parce que dans l'article il y a des
scènes où on voit les entraîneurs qui
arrivent et qui assiste même des jeunes
à torturer entre guillemets d'autres
à ce niveau là j'ai jamais eu de
plaintes ou jamais eu de dossiers qui a
été soulevé à l'effet qui a eu des
entraîneurs qui ont participé à des
initiations aussi dégradantes que celles
mentionnée dans l'article de Monsieur
Leclerc
vous n'aviez jamais j'ai le cours d'eau
U20 qu'il y avait des initiations qui
virent mal
jamais qu'on a eu qu'on était mis au
courant de ces situations l'un des
initiations qui viennent à mal
cet effet-là comme c'était à l'époque
parce que moi je suis en pause depuis
1986 comme c'était à l'époque dans les
années c'est
80-90 c'est des initiations dans
différents niveaux de sport pas
uniquement dans la digue en major du
Québec ou dans la vie canadienne de
hockey était
parti courantes et nous depuis l'année
2008 on a mis fin à ça en indiquant nos
équipes depuis l'année 2000 que c'était
tolérance zéro
un des plaignants jouaient à Mountain
aux dernières nouvelles Monteux ne fait
partie de la Ligue de hockey majeur du
Québec
oui effectivement
Stephen kart qui avait déposé une
plainte on était au courant de la
plainte on a malheureusement pas au
courant je n'étais malheureusement pour
moi j'ai jamais entendu parler de ce que
Stéphane quark a pu avoir comme
initiation à Moncton je l'ai appris
lorsque ce dernier a soumis son Afida
vite à la cour
comment se fait-il que ça a pu durer
monsieur Courtot autant d'années ce
genre de débordement là sans que vous et
les responsables à la Ligue mettent fin
à la situation
moi comme je vous dis on a mis on a mis
une réglementation tolérance zéro depuis
2000 lorsqu'on a procédé à notre Charmed
de constitution et depuis cette année-là
quand il survenu des situations où on
est nécessaire l'intervention d'ailleurs
on a fait une Sherbrooke en 2018
lorsqu'un joueur européen avait
mentionné qui avait subi qui aurait subi
des situations complètement
inappropriées on a fait un kite et ça
c'est avéré non véridique ce que le
joueur avait mentionné qui était survenu
puis là il y a mission sur le dos de
mauvaises interprétations de mauvaise
traduction ok mais les événements
relatés par Martin Leclerc qui sont
relatés dans le dans le dossier de cours
ça va jusqu'en 2014 comment se fait-il
que ça puisse poursuivre qu'en 2014
mais à ce niveau-là dans le moment des
éléments qui sont amenés comme j'ai
mentionnés tantôt mis à part Stephen
kwork je ne suis pas au courant s'il y a
d'autres joueurs qui proviennent la
Ligue Julien majeure du Québec qui ont
soumis une plainte au niveau du dossier
du recours collectif qui avait été
demandé à l'origine et comme je vous dis
quand nous de notre côté on était mis au
courant des faits on a investigué comme
il se devait ce Courtault pas très croit
a dit au soleil hier même type pas très
croyant il y a pas une petite
personnalité il dit quand je me rendais
plus jeune à l'Arena j'avais peur
parfois de du sort que j'allais subir
par les plus vieux est-ce que c'est
normal de vivre dans ce climat quand on
joue à qui on a 16 17 18 19 ans
non c'est absolument pas normal c'est
inacceptable c'est pas comme ça qu'on
veut former nos jeunes à ce niveau là
c'est la façon dont on veut les former
c'est de pratiquer leur sport en
sécurité
avec intégrité de leur permettre de se
développer comme il se doit dans un
environnement sain
mais comment ça se fait que ça n'a pas
été le cas pendant autant d'années
monsieur Courtot
mais comme je vous dis nous on a mis en
place la règle depuis 2000 monsieur Roy
qui ont mis cette réglementation là et
qu'on a mis ça en place puis pour nous
autres
ont eu des situations qui étaient
considérées ou qui j'étais rapporté on
est intervenu c'était fait on peut pas
dire que c'était le silence dans notre
ligue dans le livre du Québec au
contraire on est intervenus je vous dis
pas que pour survenu des situations
qu'on n'a pas été mis au courant
malheureusement si c'est le cas c'est
très malheureux qu'on espère que les
joueurs concernés vont pouvoir faire des
représentations appropriées est-ce que
un terminal ce Courtault on doit encore
d'après vous faire un effort pour
changer la culture ou hacker dans les
vestiaires la culture de gros la culture
machisme et que et que de redonner un
coup de roue pour que ces choses là ne
surviennent jamais pour que les jeunes
garçons les jeunes filles qui jouent à
qui aussi
entre l'Arena le cœur en paix
je vais entièrement raison on est
toujours à l'affût comme vous êtes
certainement au courant on a plusieurs
politiques programmes de mis en place de
prévention on a de l'éducation qu'on
fait avec les joueurs constamment avec
le support des des équipes avec le
personnel des équipes nous on était la
première ligue junior au Canada à mettre
au programme d'aide aux joueurs en place
avec l'embauche madame Natacha Lorraine
sur une exemployée de la GRC qui
fonctionne très bien on a beaucoup on
était la première ligue qui a mis une
politique antidopage en place dans la
ligue de junior majeure du Québec alors
on est toujours à l'affût de ce qu'on
peut faire pour améliorer l'encadrement
de joueur sur et orgas et on est
toujours ouvert de nouvelles idées pour
pouvoir faire en sorte d'améliorer
l'encadrement de nos droits mais vous
allez reconnaître avec moi monsieur
Courtot que le premier réflexe de la
Ligue de hockey majeur junior du Québec
hier c'était de dire ah ça nous concerne
pas
c'est la Ligue canadienne qui est qui
existe pas en fait c'est un chapeau qui
regroupe 3 lignes donc première réflexe
on reste dans le vestiaire sans jeu de
mots là
perception n'a pas voulu rester dans le
dessin donc tout simplement voulu
respecter la façon dont ça fonctionne
depuis le début dans le dossier de du
recours collectif ça a toujours été le
président des canadienne qui fait des
interventions et n'ont pas les
commissaires des respectives c'est ce
qu'on a voulu faire hier malheureusement
je connais pas les raisons pourquoi que
le président a des canadienne n'est pas
intervenu auprès des demandes
médiatiques mais aujourd'hui de concert
avec notre responsa des communications
Maxime loin on a décidé de répondre aux
demandes d'entrevue des médias j'ai le
Corto commissaire de la Ligue de hockey
junior majeur du Québec merci de nous
avoir parlé en direct
au revoir